sa radio à 9 km sur l'a4 mairie a été un
as fait tout près de 200 et oui c'est un
exploit formidable et il avait ce défi
qui me tenait à réaliser ben il l'a fait
on est content il a fait pour la ligue
contre le cancer il a fait contre toutes
les autres maladies
c'est pour la santé des martiniquais
nous sommes contents le le défi est de
gagner le pari réussi c'était difficile
c'est dur la table du diable la
caravelle ouais c'est mieux parce que
après la caravelle à la longue des sans
terre sainte marie il a beaucoup
souffert quand il vient aussi mais après
bon sens la descente et d'un
intéressante et l'arrivée en apothéose à
fort de france où et c'est formidable
ben le mois d'octobre c'est un mois où
l'on vit à tous vous travaillez dans le
cadre d'octobre rose avec la ligue
contre le cancer
et cette année nous avons rajouté ces
deux défis le discours que de christophe
des fidjis parce que nous sommes
vraiment impliqué dans le mouvement
imprimé mon blog ne m'a pas
toutes les maladies et répliquer avec la
ligue contre le cancer
donc on ne lâche pas le bout on va en
effet on travaille avec nos chouchous